if you love doing it but nobody cares
you have a hobby great and it might be
really fulfilling and soulful for you
but it's not a business great
right like you praying while you eat
your breakfast is not a business no but
it fills you up but soulful exactly if
you need to do it if you're only chasing
opportunity but you don't love the thing
you're gonna lose because the people who
love that well they're gonna win it's
they're gonna crush you like you can
only do something you hate for so long
so it's in that combination that what
you love doing with where there's an
opportunity so my name is Liam Alexis
and I am a faith-based coach as well as
a praise moves praise kicks mera
instructor I truly believe that the mind
body and spirit are one I know that your
tagline is believe ya which works well
with what you're doing for sure but
sometimes there's that that dark circle
of doubt where you're sort of sitting
there going I believe in what I'm doing
I believe I'm called to what I'm doing
yeah but then there's that no you're not
good enough you're not really supposed
to do that how do you stay true to
yourself and maintain that belief
without losing your ever-loving mind I
think it's a few ways to do it I think
especially if you're a person of faith
there's a great passage from Luke Luke
42 something I don't know anyway it's
like if if you've been giving gifts and
you have the responsibility like it's
yeah what like Spider Man has has Oh
taking over it was like if you have if
you have the if with great power comes
get responsibility like you have you
been giving gifts yes if being have you
been given amazing gifts I can help
people yes then it's your duty it's like
you are obliged you have to you have to
right and so I would whatever it is that
gets you feeling bold and confident and
unstoppable you've had moments in your
life when you felt bold and unstoppable
absolutely but just not consistent
and and welcome to being a human right
it's like this isn't just silly an thing
isn't everybody thing so doing the thing
that helps you feel bold and unstoppable
as part of your morning a lot of
entrepreneurs have these different
multiple streams of income okay I guess
my question is what is your thought
process on that like nah I know from a
holistic process of course that's wise
because you if you put all your eggs in
one basket so I really hate the idea of
multiple streams of no cam Oh especially
at the beginning that's a great
investment strategy so if you--if you're
investing in a stock market it's a great
investment strategy to diversify I think
as an entrepreneur people diverse people
diversify themselves out of a business
that's the problem okay
just like what social media networks
should I be on and they go everywhere
and then they suck everywhere and so
this is maybe where I'm a little
different than what people are preaching
but I look at someone like Andrew
Carnegie who's the richest man in the
world at one point and he said put all
your eggs in one basket
okay and then watch that basket okay
right like if you are gonna do
faith-based coaching you could become
the best faith-based coach in the world
but to do that takes a lot of work a lot
of effort a lot of training a lot of
practice a lot of sessions of like a lot
a lot a lot on go go go right if you're
doing that and you're also trying to
write code for something and you're also
trying to just like you never get you
never get mastery to anything great and
then you make little tiny bits of income
from all these places but because you're
never actually that good at something
you never get rewarded for it not just
financially but also the impact that the
ability to change people's lives ability
to make improvement and so I think I
love the idea of putting all your eggs
in one basket and then being amazing at
that thing and then people say well what
if what if the economy collapses or what
if you put everything in on YouTube and
that thing goes away
you've built your brand and you built a
skillset that you can take anywhere
right okay so do you know the Paul
Brothers look and Paul Jake Paul yeah so
they they they were on this platform
called fine which was so vine was like
quick really short videos they blew up
they were taking over vine and then vine
shut down gone so they came to YouTube
and they blew up YouTube and they've got
you know 10 million subscribers plus or
something crazy like that I don't know
we're in like in a year year and a half
why because all the skills they
developed for themselves on vine they
could transport over to YouTube so
people say don't put all your eggs in
the vine basket because I might shut
down great and it did but if you get
good at the skill its communicating
right right if you get great at
communicating you can take that anywhere
for life
so for me putting everything on like I'm
all-in on YouTube and I'm building up my
Instagram now okay like I'm going
hardcore Instagram now okay there's 24
people on my team you know right it's
like yeah so I haven't I have the
resources to do it properly but if
YouTube and Instagram both went away I
would jump on something else and start
to destroy that thing okay because of
all the skills that I've developed great
so I would pick like to run four
businesses at the same time is difficult
great so pick the one thing that you
feel most connected to and then gain
mastery in that thing being the best or
being among the best or being
world-class at helping me learn the
message whether that's through your
coaching sessions whether that's through
an Instagram video whether that's
through me working out with you right
whatever
helping me understand how to bring that
into my life is never gonna go anywhere
okay right like it's there forever but
you have to be good at doing that thing
right and just stick to it
you need to figure out what you want to
be world-class a train and then just and
then the how will change a lot like for
me and Mike I went from Facebook to link
their LinkedIn to Facebook to Twitter to
YouTube were now Instagram and I had
these moments and you'll you'll have
moments of opportunity windows of
opportunity right like you could you
could start an Instagram channel now and
start building up momentum right but
maybe in three years Instagram isn't the
thing anymore okay and so great but if
you learn how to make a great video and
communicate a message you take that
anywhere you take that to the the
Minster gram that starts up right and
then you're you're all over that but the
the skill that you are building is there
for life like what your mission is not
changing great and so being great at
executing your mission is what you need
to stick to it ofthis on the how you
often accomplish it can change like
maybe right now it sprays moves
they've been two years you know you
don't want to praise moves maybe you
want to do more like coaching one-on-one
right or maybe you want to be a speaker
or maybe you want to be an author or
maybe you want to be a right right it's
still the same message and it's still
getting great because if you want to be
a speaker on stage you've built your
skills by doing praise moves great and
by doing the coaching I'm working with
like you can't be a great speaker on
stage to 5,000 people if you don't know
how to help people one-on-one sure
because the people on that you're
helping on stage you see the faces of
the people that you've helped one-on-one
great that's why you're great because
you've done all that work so it doesn't
mean you have to do one thing forever
doesn't mean you have to do praise moves
forever you'd have to be the best praise
moves person of all three you need to be
the best at taking Christianity and
applying it to in my life or among the
best right right so you were talking I'm
listening to what you're saying and you
were talking about going
Facebook to LinkedIn to Twitter right so
I guess just the momentum of that you
will determine where you switch from to
right it's a combination of like what I
love doing with where there's an
opportunity okay
so YouTube became this this magical
storm for me because I love video
I love visuals so if we were having this
conversation where our eyes were closed
it'd be a lot harder for me okay because
I can i'd have to focus so much if it's
only auditory I have a really hard time
I could do it but I have to stress
myself to do it
so I don't listen any podcasts okay a
podcast was the only way to learn I
would do it but I'm it's the hardest way
for me to learn so because there's video
it's gonna go there
so YouTube became this perfect storm for
me because it's video and because I've
developed a skill to be good on video
there are a lot of practice and work and
so that's where I focus my energy and
efforts now Twitter is becoming video
and LinkedIn is becoming video like but
when I was in it it wasn't and it's
still not quite like if you thinking
video YouTube is the place for video
okay I also want my content to live
forever right yes and YouTube is YouTube
it nope none besides YouTube okay
Instagram no Twitter no LinkedIn no
Facebook no you're not looking at
something that's a week old on any of
those platforms but I videos on YouTube
that are five years old and still
getting views okay you have an impact
that's what I want like I want my work
to live forever like I want to have
impact forever so that's the perfect
form of YouTube but at the same time I
like testing things and so I tested
Instagram okay and I and I tested
Instagram live specifically and I did
one and then some people wanted to join
in somebody said they asked to join in
like oh you could bring people in oh
cool you could bring people in this is
amazing right and then like I'm helping
somebody from Alabama than somebody from
Russia and then somebody from Japan you
know and they come in on the chat and
even though there were technical issue
and like echoes and it's chaos because I
also didn't know what I was doing at the
beginning I just loved the fact that I
could bring people in and help them
one-on-one and so I was going live on
YouTube once a week but it was just
answering text questions okay
people at a chat a question but often
the the best answer is like you have to
go to three questions deep to actually
get to the real question Rahab right so
with with Instagram life you could do
that so because I loved it so much then
I started going live five times a week
plus on Instagram okay so there's a
combination of what you love doing with
where there's an opportunity okay if you
love doing it but nobody cares you have
a hobby right okay and and it might be
really fulfilling and soulful for you
but it's not a business great right like
you praying while you eat your breakfast
is not a business no but it's it fills
you up but soulful exactly if you need
to do it if you're only chasing
opportunity but you don't love the thing
you're gonna lose because the people who
love that will they're gonna win they're
gonna crush you like you can only do
something you hate for so long great so
it's in that combination of what you
love doing with where there's an
opportunity okay cool because I'm I'm
doing the Facebook lives now
yeah but then having Polonia yes like a
good friend yeah and watching her shift
and just going I'd like to get to that
point right and it's not that I don't
think I can yeah
I'm just sort of like how do you know
that you know basically how do you know
that you know that you know that you
know yeah so sort of like I doing what I
do
yeah you don't know until you do but you
won't think your way through this and
that's the box the box won't figure it
out on the couch like think you cannot
think your way through it exactly you
have to do it so here's the here's the
beautiful thing
all of those strategies work every
strategy that you read in the book or
watch a video on or podcast they all can
work by sifting it's Facebook Ads works
Facebook live works
have an Instagram channel it works doing
old school like Colin people can work
meeting people partnerships it all works
everything works but what works for you
it won't work for you because you you
won't like some of the stuff great and
that's a trick you have to like the
process what do you enjoy the processed
a result because the results as you get
a new client and you love working with
your client exactly
you love coaching them and working it
with them and all that but the process
to get the client you have to that the
marketing path is gonna be the one that
you actually feel the most okay so maybe
even though I said like the morning
prayer isn't isn't a business like maybe
becomes like maybe you do Instagram live
with your morning prayer or YouTube
video of your morning prayer like some
people have no idea how to pray true
true and and then that's true and here
and it's like listen it's not that
difficult you close your eyes and you
see you're grateful for it it's true
yeah and here's how I do it and maybe I
start with a piece of scripture that I
like like whatever your process is
people will then start to follow that
cool that's giving me actually like
again lightbulbs massive ideas because
and not necessarily in the marketplace
marketable but just sharing because I
need to do you three and when kids come
into your so it's very different when
you work with adults and when you work
with young people young people have
absolutely no holds barred they have no
fear whereas adults we go through this
process of okay well I can't I can't I
can't because I've told all of my kids
they can't can't can't so therefore I
can't and when it comes to sharing like
just be bold like what you're saying and
a lot of adults they just can't find the
way to be bold and Kant is actually a
word that's not in my vocabulary I'm
just using it for now but when I think
of the young people we sit there I'm
like okay so we're gonna pray we did a
whole season of let's hell let's learn
how to pray okay and
the first young person said well I'm not
really sure I know how yeah you know way
it's like talking to your mom talking to
your dad you just keep your eyes open
keep your eyes closed and now I'm
thinking well if I could teach it in a
youth ministry why can't I share that on
their YouTube on Facebook and there's no
again no written law this is you can't
do that yeah so now I'm just thinking
huh yeah my book and even even as you
said that of saying it's like talking to
your mom or your dad like that's your
perspective but that's like that's your
way of doing it which is different yeah
because I've I've never heard anybody
explain it like that so even though like
you're sick you're seeing it one way and
your pastor will say it a different way
and like TD jakes will say it a
different way and like you know I'm
Bishop Jake's been on my channel a
couple times and like he'll he'll like
he'll like yell at you like yeah touch
somebody and ride you know like that's
his style you know you will have the
same message but the way that you
deliver it will be different you'd be
like hey just breathe yeah like imagine
you talking to your mom right and so the
way that people will connect with you
will be different than other people and
people need the connection like they're
not getting it through what's currently
available out there and so your voice
matters I was sharing before that I do
Brazilian Jujitsu yeah and because of
two car accidents I haven't been able to
get back on the mats I haven't been
cleared yet but I'm fighting to get on
the mats yeah because that was fun super
fun yeah although those guys are bigger
and they throw me around like a rag doll
but it was super fun and some of them
would call me like a little warrior
princess because I'm just like a little
Terrier just like going back at them and
I thought okay so a warrior princess
does not stop a warrior princess doesn't
get fearful she just Xena princess so
that's what this was today so although I
talked to Paul Meunier she's like you
know just go do it and I thought okay
and as I'm driving here I'm like
do this freaked out and I was getting
closer and closer I'm getting freaked
out like it's okay and then I remembered
what you said in your video which is
what you just said okay is that if if
you don't have anything in your calendar
that freaks you out right you don't like
your life yeah yeah and not in a selfish
way I just I love my life and I'm like
oh wait everything in my calendar is
nothing that I would one in zero yeah
you know nothing yeah you don't want
that life it's you know what it's like
maybe I didn't it was enough yeah you
know so now I'm just like every moment
of the day is a freak out moment and
it's all good it's super cool so you
take that message of fight to get back
on the mats like that's a message so you
could make you a quick video talking
about hey you need to fight to get back
on the mats you can tell your story but
then make it relevant to everybody right
okay like the mats is an analogy for
life right or that could be so that
could be like a motivational rant or
could be a really soft like I feel like
I'm getting hugged with you talking
about it you leave with empathy or could
be a prayer in the morning like you're
gonna pray to remember to fight to get
on the mats today like my intention for
the day you know so it's like super
quiet and soft but see that's the thing
like figuring out your style and what
you love doing
that's crazy cool I love it oh my gosh
oh my gosh okay so what's the first
thing to test to just test to see what I
like just to go and just run okay so
like I'll get on my my video and just
start seeing if I can not even seeing if
just do it and it's still morning you
know yeah Lots you got the whole day I
do the same message that's okay so how
you gonna do it then you're gonna you're
gonna make an Instagram live you're
gonna make a video you're gonna do
prayer you're gonna you're gonna yell at
somebody like what are you gonna do I
think I well now that you showed me how
to get on Instagram life properly I'm
gonna do an Instagram life
and I'll probably just sit on my mat
yeah and talk about a little bit about
my story
yeah and pray about what the next step
is to definitely fight to get there
great and how easy it is to just take
that very next step
yeah it may seem debilitating but it
isn't great
it really isn't you're not gonna die so
expect it expected to suck it's like
nobody to show up and and that's where a
lot of people end up losing is because
oh like nobody showed up or like only
one person saw that oh I spent all this
time and nobody nobody cares about my
stuff I'll just keep going yeah well did
you enjoy it
forget the results did you enjoy the
process like I didn't really know I was
doing but I liked it like this is kind
of fun yeah right this is fun like I
could come on I like having a message
every I like having a message every day
I like it
like it sets me up for the day yeah and
then I I don't feel complete until I've
shared it it's not just thinking I need
to share exactly my morning routine
isn't complete without me sharing
something that sets me up to feel bold
and like ready to attack the day if I
wake up and I don't share message I
don't have as great a day okay and
that's not the way I do it is I usually
like get angry and yell into the camera
I mean with you
right what do you play it's like it's
the same message just I might be yelling
them and you're gonna be hugging them
right like Oprah and TD jakes have a lot
of similar messages right but their
delivery styles completely different
yeah and some people just gravitate more
towards one awesome people gravitate
towards your style and you're still
honing and figured out your style like
you don't know what it is because you're
just starting Rea even done one yet
awesome but did you enjoy the process
and if you did then you can go back to
it and do it on a regular rockin cool
because if you keep doing it and you
keep loving it you will you will blow up
it's like you can't ignore that if you
do it every day for five years and you
got still three people watching
then something's wrong Yeah right okay
yeah great but if you did it for two
weeks and you haven't got
results okay use fine there's like a
little bit more patience like it's gonna
happen so the results will come as a
result of you doing work that you love
and that is providing value for people
if you want to get coached by me
one-on-one to help you build your brain
and make money as a thought leader check
out my next workshop in Toronto the link
is right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there